[Music]
hello everyone
i'm alexander rose i'm the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and i'm joining you
live from our headquarters in san
francisco
uh a sadly very quiet version of the
interval
cafe and bar um and
um tonight we're actually going to be
sharing with you
yet another experiment in our various
forms of
creating new ways of doing online talks
for all of you
uh during this time of pandemic when we
all have to record these
from our our homes and places of work um
that we can um so in for this week
or month we have actually pre-recorded
the talk
and i've edited it and we're going to
air it uh with you and rick
dublin our speaker tonight is going to
see that edit for the first time along
with you
and then join in at the end for a live
question and answer
as well as two of our founders kevin
kelly and stuart brand
this talk is one that i've been working
for a long time to
to bring to this audience and uh
fundamentally humans have been using
psychedelic substances for thousands of
years
but it's really only recently that
they're finding ways
uh to a much more um
kind of accepted version in our society
both for medicinal
and in less formal circles obviously for
recreational use
but pretty much all of that advocacy and
research that you have been seeing
um has really come from very few points
in the world and one of those
uh is rick dublin who spent the last
40 years or more of his life most of his
life really on this problem
and so tonight he's going to share that
with us welcome rick
well thank you very much i really
appreciate this opportunity
to speak with you all today
since uh it's the long now foundation i
really wanted to start with a very
long-term perspective and so
while we're talking about trying to
integrate psychedelics into the
mainstream
into western culture the last time that
actually was the case was 396 a.d
1624 years ago and that was when
the goths sacked lucius and
wiped out the elusinian mysteries which
had been going for almost
two millennia starting in 1600 bc around
then
396 a.d and the elastinian mysteries
were involving a potion that was drunk
called
kikion and they've figured out that this
was
moldy rye and barley that they used um
air got
that can produce a psychedelic
experience and that's where lsd was
actually derived
it's synthetic but it came from air guys
so i think it's just really important to
think about
the fact that we're
engaged in a sense in something that's
uh
3 200 years and it's been 1624 years
since
the psychedelics have really been
accepted in full
in the mainstream in western culture so
that can suggest that
when psychedelics really emerged into
the culture in the 60s
it was after a very long hiatus and it
was very difficult emergence
and resulted in a terrible backlash and
now
50 years later we're emerging from that
so i think that's the the big
perspective that we need to keep
now while i talked about psychedelics
being
sort of used in culture in our western
culture
over 3000 years ago my story my long now
begins 50 years ago you know as i was
growing up i was very much
reading i was born in 53 and raised on
stories of the holocaust
and that just terrified me that people
could be so cruel to other people and
then for me
the next step was the vietnam and that
was my own country that was doing things
and i was searching for solutions in a
crazy world that's
murder all over the place so when i was
17 years old i went to college new
college in florida in sarasota florida
it was an experimental college and it
still is it's the honors college of
florida right now
and they had all night parties with
psychedelics till sunrise
with dance parties with hundreds of
people and i thought wow this
is really great so i felt that this was
an oasis of sanity
in a crazy world and lo and behold i
came across the
whole earth catalog and this was
absolutely pivotal
in my development because i read this
whole earth catalog
and in it was a little report about a
book
called programming and meta programming
in the human bio computer by john lilly
john lilly who invented the flotation
tank and then did lsd in the flotation
tank
as an effort to try to really understand
how
the brain is working and this was very
inspiring to me
so i tried to do lsd
in this sensory deprivation environments
we didn't have a flotation tank but we
did reduce sensory input things like
that
and that got to be very difficult this
was now again
after 1970 the control substances act
the 60s had crashed and burned nixon was
elected the psychedelic research was
wiped out
and i had difficult time with my
psychedelic experiences
and so i went to the guidance counselor
this was
the spirit of the time quest into the
unknown that's why i really felt
that i wanted to do this exploration and
i went to the guidance counselor
though and said i i need trouble help
with my tripping and the guidance
counselor said
there's a book i'd like you to read by
stan groff who's kind of the
world expert on lsd research he helped
start
transpersonal psychology the book was
realms of the human unconscious
observations from lsd research and in it
stan said
psychedelics are to the study of the
mind what the microscope is to biology
and the telescope is to astronomy
and i felt very inspired by this book
and this is where my life sort of
crystallized where i realized that here
he was talking about the realms of the
human unconscious
he was talking about psychodynamic areas
but also about
the sort of death rebirth process and
then transpersonal states
which i felt also had these important
political connections
but stan was wrapping this in a
scientific
framework it wasn't a dogmatic religious
framework it was scientific framework it
was using psychedelics
in a scientific study of the mind and it
had the
for me the very crucial reality check
of psychotherapy can you use these
insights about the mind about
the unconscious to actually help people
deepen their participation in life
so i thought it's a crazy world and this
is a long term
strategy i felt that lots of people were
doing lots of other
shorter term strategies but i felt that
this helping people have the sense of
connection was the antidote to
fundamentalism to genocide
and that even though the psychedelic
research had been suppressed
i felt like it was the most important
thing that i could be working on and i
didn't know if it would succeed or not
but it didn't really matter
and so this was the critical point for
me where i focused
my life on psychedelics the first thing
i did was
i dropped out of college tune in turn on
drop
out and i felt that i needed to get
grounded and build things so i
built this handball court um then i end
up building this house
with a lot of help actually i still have
this house all these years later
um this big stained glass window inside
of it
and this led other people to come to ask
me to build houses for them so i
basically had a decade of of getting
grounded
trying to be balanced so that i could go
back to put psychedelics as the
forefront
i 10 years later i went back to the same
college and i took a month-long workshop
in 1982
at eslin with stan and christina groff
and that's where i learned about mdma
so the history of mdma begins in 1912
when it was first synthesized and
patented patented by
merck but they didn't do anything at all
until 1927
and merck did some preclinical studies
in animals and found
nothing of interest and they decided to
just shelve the compound this is
around the time their patent is going to
expire the next we
know of mdma is uh the army chemical
warfare service mkultra looking for mind
control drugs
and then sasha shogun who was an
incredible chemist
he started looking for new drugs for
psychotherapy and for personal growth
and spirituality
and he re-synthesized mdma experimented
with it on himself
and felt that it had incredible
potential
for therapy and so he gave it to leo
zeff
who was the leader of the underground
psychedelic psychotherapy
community from the middle 70s to the
early 80s roughly half a million doses
of mdma were used in therapeutic growth
settings
mostly by people that leo had trained
and it was found to be
useful in a wide variety of conditions
but it leaked out of that community
became sold as ecstasy and this was at
the time of nancy reagan
and just say no and the rise of the drug
war again and so it was clear that it
was doomed so this was an incredible
opportunity to gather support
to prepare for the defense of mdma once
the drug
enforcement administration finally
decided to move against it
it was in dallas at the start club where
ecstasy really became popular mdma
became popular as ecstasy
in a dance club setting george bush all
sorts of people
participated here and this is what
attracted the attention the dea
so in the summer of 84 dea moved to put
mdma
in schedule 1. they only knew about it
as a party drug they didn't know about
it as
a therapy drug and so in 1987 when i
graduated college
i couldn't get into a clinical psych phd
program and so i decided i don't know
what i'm going to do now with my life i
smoked some pot and i thought i'll think
about it while i'm high
and i realized i had a pattern which is
i want too much too soon
i want to do the polit i want to do the
science but the politics is in the way
so i need to pivot and study the
politics
so in 86 i started maps as a non-profit
maps is the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
mdma is the most general of all the
psychedelics that's why i felt it would
be the first one
to make it through the system for the
first six years the fda
rejected five different protocols from
harvard medical school uc san francisco
elsewhere
and it was just we're just starting to
emerge from this
period of uh multiple decades of total
repression
of psychedelic research so in 1992
charlie grobe and i obtained approval
from the fda
for the first phase one dose response
safety study for mdma
in humans so that was major major
breakthrough
and i started working with ptsd
with dr michael mithofer and also
we started first off in spain to try to
do research here
we were having trouble getting
permission in the u.s for a
actual patient study this study in spain
was the first mdma ptsd research ever
and the tragedy was that it got a lot of
media
but that alerted the madrid anti-drug
authority and they shut the study down
for political reasons so then we went
back
to our efforts in the u.s and we got fda
approval but we couldn't get
institutional review boards to permit us
to do a study
in the u.s and a bunch of these had re
rejected the protocol
so i said let me just try one more time
and i noticed that one of these private
companies that reviews irbs was called
copernicus and i felt if anybody is
sympathetic to
political religious pressure on science
it would be the copernicus group and
lo and behold they ended up approving
the study
we ended up doing a series of phase two
pilot studies
in the united states in israel in canada
and in switzerland we did a study in
military veterans firefighters and
police officers that we published in the
lancet but these studies were all done
from basically 16 years from 2000 to
2016.
so we gathered all of this phase two
data and
at this point now that we're starting to
show benefits
neuroscientists started getting
interested and this was something that i
could have very impressed from stanford
boris heifetz and rob malenka the
world's populations need more compassion
and empathy for one another
the study of mdma provides one small but
potentially important step towards
reaching that goal
so this is a call to action for the
world neuroscientists to study mdma
not just for therapeutic purposes but
for compassion and empathy so it gets
back to kind of the
political reasons that got me into
psychedelics in the first place
and what had also been known is that if
you have ptsd
um it changes your brain you have
hyperactive amygdala where you process
fear you have reduced activity in the
prefrontal cortex so you're not thinking
as logically and
hippocampus where we store memories into
long-term storage
activity is reduced so this is kind of
the brain changes that you get from ptsd
mdma changes your brain also but in the
opposite way
so it reduces activity in the amygdala
so things that were
fearful before are not so fearful people
talk about
self-love self-acceptance looking able
better able to look at difficult things
mdma increases activity in the
prefrontal cortex
which increases your logical thinking
triggers that might remind somebody of
a trauma noise that instantaneously they
go into a fear-based reaction now they
can have a moment to think about it
separate it out think more logically
and mdma increases activity between the
amygdala and the hippocampus
to facilitate the storage of these
traumatic memories into long term
so that they're not always about to
happen in people's perceptions
so ptsd changes your brain mdma changes
it in the opposite way
researchers also found and published a
paper in 2019 in nature
to show that mdma stimulates oxytocin
the hormone of love nursing mothers
connection
and that that opens up this critical
learning period but
also it promotes new neural connection
so you are actually rewiring your brain
in pro-social ways
and that can explain why just a few
experiences sometimes just one can have
long-lasting therapeutic benefits
so after 30 years of maps from 1986 to
2016 after we had all of our phase 2
data
we went to the fda for an end of phase 2
meeting
where you present your data and say can
we go to phase three
which is the final stage of research you
need to prove safety and efficacy
and we presented this data we said that
in the control group which is therapy
without active mdma
we had a chronic severe treatment
resistant people
and 23 of them at the two months after
the last experimental session no longer
had ptsd
so this is really tremendous from just
from psychotherapy basically by itself
and this is comparable with other
psychotherapy so this showed that our
control group
and our therapy component was actually a
good control because we were trying hard
and people were getting somewhat better
from that treatment but when you add
mdma to the therapy you get up to 56
percent more than twice as
much and so this was really remarkable
finding
but we also did a long-term follow-up
one year later
and what we showed is that people keep
getting better the two-thirds no longer
have ptsd and of the wonder that still
do have ptsd
most of them had clinically significant
reduction of ptsd symptoms
and if we could have given them one or
two more mdma sessions maybe they would
also no longer have ptsd but what this
showed is that
the experience that people go through is
durable
and that people learn to process trauma
they keep getting better on their own so
this is fundamentally different than
normal treatments for ptsd from big
pharma where you get a drug and it's
supposed to correct a biochemical
deficit and you take the drug every day
for months or years or decades
we're just trying to do get to the root
of the problem we're not talking about
addressing symptoms we're addressing
root causes and we're trying to do it in
a
deep intensive psychotherapeutic process
to make people free of drugs we're not
trying to make them keep using mdma
so just to give you a sense of the
therapy
this is a roughly two minute video of
one of the veterans that was in our
study
he two tours in iraq and his problem was
rage
that when he came back he would um
he was first off he couldn't work he was
traumatized he had a very difficult time
but but he also would blow up at us
at his wife and throw things never hit
her or hurt her directly but
rage was what he was dealing with and so
um
here is two minutes of his therapy
session
i never realized how much i
i thought i was being a peaceful person
but i didn't realize how much i was
punishing that
that that aspect of me
i think i was just i think maybe in iraq
i saw what it was capable of
and i think i was too afraid to
you know and a part of me just feels
like
so bad that i i did that
to him i mean i know it's
me but i just described
that's really amazing
i don't know i just got this amazing
sense of just
i guess wisdom i really don't know
sounds a lot like wisdom to me yeah it
was
really amazing and you try and think of
that really rachel aspect of me like i
can't even
i know it's there but it just doesn't
i really feel like so much more at peace
with
like everything okay even if i try and
think about
iraq and everything
like i somehow feel
like really peaceful
about the fact that that's my journey
and that
yeah thanks for sharing that part of me
thank you i mean
i mean i know this is
part of the uh you know part of the drug
but
when i try and think you know am i going
to be able to hold on to this um
this understanding and this
um somewhat of wisdom this knowledge
that i have now
mm-hmm
let i just ask myself that question i
feel like it's so profound that i don't
think i could really
forget it so that was
um over 12 years ago he did not forget
it
and he no longer has ptsd and he hasn't
taken mdma since the study
there's a certain courage that it takes
for people to confront their traumas and
if they're not willing to do that the
mdma helps them to do that but it can't
do the work for them so
we feel like we're more like midwives
than
anything else and that people have to do
the work themselves so
we have found there's a great video a
documentary called trip of compassion
and it's about three of our israeli ptsd
patients
and their therapy now they were all
successes but but some of the times you
can see that it's nothing like the video
that i showed
they're shaking they're they're sweating
they're they're terrified they're
they're hiding under their pillows
and they're blankets that that it's it's
very very difficult
for some people to to work through to
process this
and a lot of times it's somaticized so
that if you can't
um sort of consciously make it things
come to people in their
pains in their body or tensions like
that
and so we've had several people who had
mdma drop out of our study because they
didn't want to work with
the powerful emotions that were coming
up and so i think for those
people that it doesn't work for they
i would recommend something more gradual
like more
psychotherapy over a prolonged period of
time
and then maybe they would then be ready
so i think that
it's about the willingness of people to
really
engage with the pain and the mdma helps
them but it doesn't do all the work
people have to be willing and if they're
not
then they won't get better so the
lessons that we learned in phase two
though
is that we can enroll people in our
studies
regardless of the cause of ptsd the
ssris zoloft and paxil that are approved
by the fda for ptsd tend to work better
in
women then and men and completely failed
in combat related ptsd but we can enroll
people with
ptsd from any cause we found that low
doses of
mdma do enhance the blinding but they
have an anti-therapeutic effect that
they
they make people more uncomfortable they
they don't reduce the fear but they
activate them
so low dose wasn't such a good placebo
control
we discovered that it's safe in clinical
settings
and that we had a medium to large effect
size that we were getting really good
results
so in after this end of phase two
meeting we went through this long
process of
negotiating with fda what's called
special protocol assessment to design
phase three so we came to agreement we
have an agreement letter
and that means fda is legally bound to
approve mdma
assisted psychotherapy for ptsd if our
studies get
statistically significant evidence of
efficacy and no new
safety problems arise ptsd
is a terrible situation six to ten
percent of all people develop ptsd in
their lifetime
18 or so more percent of iraq war
veterans develop ptsd it's higher in
conflict zones
and only 40 to 60 percent of patients
respond adequately
to available treatments there's over a
million veterans this is september 2018.
over a million veterans are disabled
with ptsd and are receiving disability
payments from the va
for ptsd it's the third most prevalent
service connected disability after
ringing in the ears and hearing loss
the va spends about 15 to 20 billion per
year in these disability payments mostly
for young people it's going to go on for
decades
and they spent in 2017 seven billion
dollars on drugs for ptsd
mostly these are ssris
this is a chart sort of effect sizes
how strong is the therapeutic effect the
fda requires you to have two phase three
studies that
are statistically significant and so
paxil had
three studies one of them failed but
they have
small to medium effect sizes whereas in
our phase two data we had a large
effect size so on the basis of this
though fda
said mdma assisted psychotherapy is a
breakthrough
treatment it's the most important
designation for the most promising drugs
and it gets you more meetings with fda
shorter timelines
in a sense we're almost partnering with
fda now
to see if this research will actually
work
our treatment is three and a half months
and there are
three mdma sessions eight hours long
with a male female co-therapy
team and people spend the night in the
treatment center most of the time
and then there's 12 90-minute non-drug
psychotherapy sessions
with three before the first mdma session
or or this would be the placebo session
the therapy without mdma and then
three of these sessions for integration
after each mdma session so you can see
from this that
it's really therapy that is enhanced by
the mdma and we have a two-person team
we
we prefer male-female team doesn't
always have to be that way
but we're really trying to optimize
patient outcomes
we've got phase three site locations as
i said before 15 of them two in israel
two in canada and eleven throughout the
united states
we've also negotiated with the european
medicines agency for a series of
meetings after we got the special
protocol assessment
with the fda and breakthrough therapy
from fda then we went to europe
and we obtained approval in june 12
2018 from the european medicine agency
scientific advice
working party to move forward to phase
three in europe as well so we're a
couple years
behind in europe than we are in the us
we've got sites picked out in about
seven countries ten locations
so we we think we're on track to succeed
in this first of two phase three studies
if this drug is approved the fda will
have special regulations on
how it's to be regulated post-approval
and it's called risk evaluation and
mitigation strategies so
it's not the drug it's the therapy so
the only people that can prescribe this
and treat patients are people that have
been trained
in the therapeutic approach and it's
only administered in clinics under
direct supervision it's never a
take-home drug
there's going to be a centralized
pharmacy that ships to the
prescribers not to the patients and
there will be certain
safety criteria the things that are
under the dotted line
are things that we may or may not have
to do the fda might want to impose
a lifetime limit of the number of times
people can get mdma
for ptsd and they might want a patient
registry but
the main aspects of this are to say it's
fundamentally different than medical
marijuana which is
a drug you take at home and do yourself
this is going to be administered only
under direct supervision
we have a therapeutic method that's
standardized based on
a lot of the early work with lsd the
basic belief is that
there's an inner healing intelligence we
support the emergence of what's
happening we don't try to
steer people to certain things we have a
training program
that trains therapists and so we've been
running training programs for
uh the last five and a half years i'm
just gonna run through them very quickly
just you can get a sense of the
the scale of the number of people that
we've trained
all over the world um this was in the
netherlands in israel
asheville north carolina this we're
getting up to the present colorado
we did a training for therapists of
color
and we did another one in asheville we
also evaluate and supervise them
as they work with one ptsd patient
everything's videotaped and our team
watches the videotapes and then we have
a
you know a week-long in-person training
so it's
rather rigorous but we think it's
optional we don't want to require
people to have to do the mdma we think
that any therapist
who's working with patients would be
better able to work with mdma if they
knew what it was themselves
you wouldn't go to a meditation teacher
that never meditated or a yoga teacher
that didn't do yoga
but we don't think we should require it
and we think the patients should be able
to
know the difference so this is just a
fun thing we made up a long time ago
there'll be a diploma
that we give to people if they've been
through successfully through our
training program
and then we'll add these if they've the
rainbows if they've taken the mdma
to show again further mainstreaming this
is a police psychotherapist
uh sarco gregarion who lives not far
from me here in boston
and he's going through our training
program to learn how to give
mdma therapy to other police officers
with trauma
so i've always felt that the police are
the predator and i'm the prey
now i have a lot more sympathy for the
police i understand their job is very
very difficult and that they need a lot
of help and therapy and so it's just
one of the proudest things for me is
working with
sarco to try to train him to help other
police officers and we think he's
only the first of many right now what's
going on is that maps
is a non-profit pharmaceutical company
set up as a nonprofit research and
educational organization
and that was started in 1986
by myself and in december 2014
we created the maps public benefit
corporation
and that's the vehicle that we're using
to do the pharmaceutical drug
development and that's the vehicle
that we'll use to market mdma by
prescription
assuming that we do get fda approval and
so this sort of virtuous circle is
people donate to maps
get a tax deduction maps invest in the
public benefit corp the public benefit
corp is a for-profit
it will conduct the research and then
eventually market mdma and whatever
profits are made
go back to the nonprofit for the mission
of the nonprofit and we'll reinvest them
in other research
just to give you a sense we're now about
80 people the
maps team has a bunch of functions which
are mainly
running the whole operation fundraising
communications
media education events operations we do
psychedelic harm reduction and we have a
small
policy and advocacy team as well then
the clinical research team
is led by a group of women who worked
together at novartis
pharmaceutical company mostly in
vaccines and they happened to like
psychedelics
a lot more than they liked vaccines and
so they
started building out our pharmaceutical
arm and so now it's about 55-60 people
in the clinical research team we've set
up the maps public benefit corporation
which is for-profit because what we
realized is that selling mdma for a
profit
is taxable we can't do that inside the
nonprofit
so we have the for-profit that will
make some money from selling mdma that
that's the story now that we can tell
our donors that we're not going to be
constantly asking you for money because
you're helping us develop an income
stream from the sale of mdma
but the for-profit branch the maps
public benefit corporation is a hundred
percent owned by the non-profit
so now that we've gotten so far along
and it looks like we're going to succeed
and it looks like there's an enormous
number of people that need this
treatment
we've been inundated by investors who
are saying we'll
you know fork over dollars to you we
just want to cut of the profits and so
we're telling them no
and what we're saying is that we're
trying and this is what we're saying to
donors is that we're trying to do two
things
the first thing is to pave the way for
making mdma assisted psychotherapy for
ptsd into a medicine to be the first in
class
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy but
the other thing we're trying to do is
build
a more sustainable non-profit that will
act as a
as a good example in the field to put
the for-profit people in check
now i'm going to talk to you about
moving into the future this is a chart
for about 50 years of the american
voters
attitudes towards the legalization of
marijuana and you can see now
it's well over two-thirds but there's a
major plateau
from around the middle 70s to the middle
90s
that was the rise of the parents
movements the anti-drug movement in the
late 70s
and then in 1996 they started moving up
and that coincided with california and
arizona in 1996
being the first medical marijuana states
and then as more medical marijuana
states came on more people
knew medical marijuana patients and saw
that it was
again a drug that was demonized that
wasn't as bad as people had said and
that
caused them to question everything and
that caused them to start thinking not
just about medical marijuana but about
legalization so
i think that same process is going to
happen with psychedelics that
legalization follows medicalization
we've now got
um in denver was the first one to make
mushrooms the lowest enforcement
priority
um oakland has expanded that they called
it decriminalized nature to plant
psychedelics
and then in oregon on the ballot in
november it's going to be the oregon
psilocybin initiative to provide
different kind of structures for people
to get psilocybin experiences
but the thing that's innovative there is
first off on a state level but also it's
not just for patients it's for personal
growth
so once mdma becomes a medicine we think
in 2022 there's going to be
all sorts of expansions of this
thousands of clinics and
decrement and we think we'll reach
licensed legalization in 2035.
this is just my my personal guess so i
think that
when i say that 2035 is going to be the
uh transition to licensed legalization i
think we're gonna need a decade or more
of these psychedelic clinics to have
tens and thousands hundred thousand or
so people
successfully treated with psychedelics
to have the the ripple
effect in culture to change people's
attitudes towards
legalization and so i think we need to
move out of this kind of psychedelic
counterculture we need to reach out to
the people that are suffering wherever
they're suffering
and try to help spiritualize them try to
help them sort of get uh back on their
life and i think that that's one of the
more important things we can do so there
may be ads like this ask your doctor if
we we're probably not going to create
that's like this but there could be um
there'll be uh this is in a san
francisco california institute foreign
is not a real ad but they do teach
people to prepare for careers in
psychedelic psychotherapy
the reason that i use them is people
have a hard time imagining
psychedelics being medicines you know so
part of the way to tell the story is to
show images
of oh this is the way it could be and so
these um
ads for marketing drugs which i think
are abomination
actually i mean america is one of the
few countries that really permits direct
to consumer ads that
we should never have those but we
figured if we made some of them
it would be a good teaching tool and so
i i think the the idea of the
psychedelic clinics the images of the
psychedelic clinics
it's a way to kind of help people grasp
something that they
don't have any examples for in their
life and so by creating these kind of
images it's uh
it's a communications tool so
psychedelics have been used for
thousands of years in the elosinian
mysteries and i think that they
have been used because they permit
a certain kind of escape from our ego
bound focus you know our ego is helping
us
to survive it's it's um you know we have
abraham maslow who's talked about the
need hierarchy and so there's um
various needs that we have and we keep
focused on that
and and we always have a sense of who we
are both for protection and for
advancement in the world and then we get
stuck in certain patterns of thought and
psychedelics
relax those patterns and they provide
this
i'd say a good example a metaphor for
example is the
copernican revolution so everybody
thought that the earth was the center of
the universe and everything revolved
around that and then we found that no
the earth is just revolving around
uh the sun and and so i think it's like
that with the eagle we think the world
is revolving around
us and the psychedelics help us have
this experience no we're just a small
a bit in a larger system and
what stan grove has talked about i
thought it was a beautiful way he said
it is that psychedelics help
the ego become transparent to the
transcendent
the ego doesn't go away the ego doesn't
die we need to be
recognizing that we're bound by birth
and death we have to
do things to survive we need that ego
but it gets enlarged you could say and
we lose
track of the bigger picture
and that's where people get depression
and meaninglessness and so psychedelics
have been
something that gives people a sense of
our participation in the larger cycles
of death and birth
and they have also been used
i would say in therapeutic ways to break
people out of patterns
but i think that the reason psychedelic
is the word that i've chosen and i think
a lot of people have centered on is it
means mind manifesting
so i went started with my own interest
roughly 50 years ago so projecting 50
years from now
we'll have psychedelic utopia and aldous
huxley wrote this book island it was the
last book that he wrote in his life
and it was about um this
vision of an eastern state governed by
reason and love but the
end of the book is that this island is
destroyed
by the oil industry they come in and
they um
mine the island and the lesson from that
is that there are no private utopias
we are in a globalization world nobody
can escape the covet virus nobody can
escape
global warming nuclear war where there's
no private utopias anymore we need to
make
uh psychedelic utopia and we need to
make the island the entire world this
uh and so i think we'll get there by
2070.
and that is my
presentation and that's the the long now
back
to 2000 or 1600 bc
and now to 2070. thank you all very much
thank you so much rick um that was
really fantastic
um and i hope you enjoyed watching uh
this first edit of your
of your talk uh you made it so much
better than my talk
no you you gave it you gave us all the
great materials so we tried to do with
it what we could
uh so i'm glad glad to hear that you
liked it
yeah we've got a lot of questions coming
in from the audience um which i'm gonna
start with here um as well as uh invite
stuart brand and kevin kelly potentially
and for a couple questions but um one of
the first ones from
james welcher uh listening on our or
watching on our youtube feed
is that you you define mdma as a
psychedelic and
and it may not really occur to people
that it's a psychedelic
um and that may not be so broadly
defined as such
uh and that maybe we talk a little bit
more about the larger psychedelic space
and why you have focused on mdma
okay yeah so you know one thing when you
kind of run a non-profit
you want to have maximum
capacity to do any thing that you think
is useful so we define
psychedelic in the broadest possible way
so psychedelic could
even mean hyperventilation
which stan groff has talked about it
doesn't require a drug
um marijuana can be a psychedelic which
is a drug though meditation can be
psychedelic to some extent so let me
just say that the classic psychedelics
like lsd like mescaline like
ayahuasca like psilocybin from mushrooms
they do act fundamentally differently
than mdma
in the sense that they are more about
dissolving the ego and having this
emergence of this
different sort of consciousness the kind
of foreground background shift that i
talked about where the ego shifts from
the foreground to the background
there's a certain letting go in a way
often people get scared sometimes they
confuse
this ego dissolution with physical death
and
sometimes people this timelessness that
happens under um
psychedelics people start thinking
they'll be trapped in these spaces
forever or the flip side is it's a
beautiful thing they're in this timeless
beautiful space
so mdma to use some more celestial
metaphors
again what i feel like is that um
mdma is is more about um
seeing um like this transparent to the
transcendent that you can
see um this bit bigger picture but the
the classic psychedelics are about
um really moving you into that bigger
picture and so i i think that
we've found that for example with ptsd
the very first work that was ever done
with psychedelic for ptsd
was done by lsd by dr bastians who was a
dutch psychiatrist and he did
work shortly after world war ii in what
he called
concentration camp syndrome and so in
that particular use
the psych the lsd really did help bring
to the surface
buried memories but it didn't really
reduce the fear
the way that mdma does and so it can be
helpful
but it's also more challenging in
certain ways
the other part of it is an important
distinction is that in an eight-hour
session
which we have our therapy sessions are
eight hours with mdma
more or less half the time people's eyes
are closed they have
um headphones on they're listening to
music they're having an interior
experience and then the other half of
the time
without any kind of script or order when
they feel it they come out and they
start talking with the therapist however
with the classic psychedelics it's more
like 90 of the time
they're having an internal experience
and only 10 of the time they're really
engaged in dialogue with the therapist
so with the classic psychedelics a lot
of the therapy what we think of as
therapy
takes place as preparation and
integration
and during the mdma therapy session a
lot more of the therapy takes place
during the session itself
and um i know that you mentioned this in
other conversations and in parts of the
talk that we might have
edited but uh that you do this with two
people and i know one of the peop one of
the therapists was off screen in the the
video that we saw
um can you say a little bit more about
why two people and what those two what
the backgrounds of those two people i
think
we've had several questions uh here from
people
around this is like so what type of
therapists uh
could um can be involved in this
okay so the the first principle to say
is that our
our a whole approach has been optimized
patient outcomes it's a controversial
drug
you know we're trying to bring something
new that's never been done before and so
that was it what do we do to get the
best possible outcomes
and so that led to the two therapist
model instead of the one therapist model
so what we also know is that a lot of
the times that people have
trauma have people recover they're
resilient
like a lot of the people are traumatized
right now by covet will be
recovering those people that tend to
develop ptsd and it's not true for
everybody but those people that
get ptsd tended to have a series of
traumas and often have difficult
attachments
um in childhood so the the
the two-person model is uh
often in a sense um not only but often
male female model it's like recreating a
supportive
parental environment that oftentimes
people didn't have as they were growing
up
it's also the case that you get two
different perspectives some people
for example a woman who's been sexually
abused and
has ptsd would be less comfortable if
it's just a male therapist if there's a
female in the room it helps
sometimes even soldiers even sometimes
prefer
sometimes to speak to a woman some of
the time they'll speak to the man
and so we recognize though oh well also
it's an eight-hour session somebody has
to go to the bathroom somebody has to
get something to eat we want always
somebody in the room if somebody had
abandonment issues
and then they come out of their uh
experience and there's nobody there
that would be you know mildly
problematic until somebody comes back in
so the two-person model is not twice as
good as the one-person model
it's it's better we think but it's not
twice as good so the big issue then
is going to be economics how do we do it
and so that's going to get to the
credential issues
so what happened during our special
protocol assessment process which was
during 2018
where we negotiated with fda the the
design of phase three
is we got them to accept and
they accepted it the lead person the
lead facilitator is a master's level
therapist
has to be licensed as a therapist but
the second person
doesn't have to have a license could be
a student working to get a license
um after that we negotiated it then
along comes two different companies
compass for for-profit
for psilocybin usona for nonprofit for
psilocybin
and then fda imposed new requirements on
them which is that the lead person had
to be an
md or a phd which we feel makes no sense
so where we want to end up is that the
lead
person is a licensed therapist
and the second person doesn't need to be
a license at all
it could be a massage therapist it could
be a music therapist it could be
somebody who just has a lot of their own
personal experience or it could be a
student or it could be another
licensed therapist i mean eventually we
also want to explore group therapy for
economic reasons as well but i think
this is going to be a part of our
critical negotiations with fda
about what are the actual credentials
that are required and so the fda has
never regulated psychotherapy
they only regulate drugs this is the
first time that they've got a drug
psychotherapy combination
and they don't really know what they're
doing and so they're trying to be
careful
and trying to do what they think is more
rigorous so oh mdphd
you know that's more advanced degrees
they must be better than a master's
level therapist but mds
don't get trained to do therapy hardly
at all and even if you're a psychiatrist
a lot of them
are psychopharmacologists more than
their therapists phds are often even in
clinical psych
are researchers as well as therapists so
it doesn't so we've had to actually
start what's called a formal dispute
resolution process with
fda it's gonna probably cost us well
over a hundred thousand dollars in legal
fees and and work
to argue this out and we've got um
22 letters from various experts in the
field why md phd doesn't make sense why
the lead person should be
a just a licensed therapist so i think
it's
really important i would like to keep
the two-person model
but it's going to depend on these
negotiations with fda let's assume we
lose it
then i think that the one person
will need to be a licensed therapist
gotcha
um thank you i'm gonna invite kevin
kelly one of our founders here at long
now in for a question
shortly um he's been sorting the
questions from our audience and a lot
have been coming in so thank you for
that
um and i just wanted to ask
one other question um
you've mentioned memory several times in
formation of long-term
memories um and i don't think we
normally associate
a good memory uh creation with uh
drugs like um mdma but you said it
counteracts something that's happening
in ptsd so
if i just wanna quickly if you could
just talk about
how how how these people are getting
long-term memories
uh from the therapy sessions and then
we'll have kevin join us
yeah well one of the amazing things that
we find
for people is that mdma enhances their
memory for the trauma
and so certain aspects of the traumatic
memory are so painful people have
submerged them so much
that they don't remember a lot of what
happened during the trauma
and so by reducing the fear and the pain
of those memories
people are able to remember more of the
trauma so in a way they're bringing to
the surface these memories and they're
permitting what's called
fear extinction and memory
reconsolidation
and so what fear extinction is as you
get over this patterned
fear-based reaction because the mdma the
drug helps you to do that and then you
can process the emotions
and memory cons reconsolidation what
that means is that
we we used to think that memory was like
taking a book off the shelf you you have
the memory you you read the book you put
it back
actually you take the book from multiple
different places it's sort of
assembled from different parts of your
brain you remember it and then you
reconsolidate
and you have to reprint the book and
this kind of explains how people's
memories are changed over time
but what we're doing is we are swapping
out so we're
enhancing the memory for the episode
episodic memory is enhanced
but through this sphere extinction
process and through
temporally people being able to put the
trauma in the past
and not like it's always about to happen
doesn't always come to them in their
nightmares
they're able to replace the emotion
that's attached to the episodic memory
so the emotion is one of more
peacefulness acceptance and it's in the
past
and so that's how mdma really can
change how people respond to their
memories enhancing
and then also swapping out different
emotions that are attached to that
memory
thank you um i'm going to invite in
kevin um we're also getting some uh mic
noise from your caller there if you
if you can isolate the mic from your
caller that'll be awesome all right
welcome kevin
hi so um we have a couple questions
about the
general um long-term
destiny or direction of psychedelics and
leon lin asks what are the trade-offs in
extending psychedelic use more broadly
and i would sort of maybe add in the
long term
do you see a role for psychedelics in
society without the need
for a therapeutic or medical setting
and then in your licensed league
legalization what is
the license i mean what does that mean
yeah okay so
first off let me say that i think that
uh when we think about the bill of
rights and we think about the
freedom of uh speech the freedom of
religion the freedom of assembly
the freedom of the press a lot of these
things are about the freedom of
thought and the freedom of ideas so i
think it's a fundamental violation of
human rights
to block people from using drugs so i
think that
the drug war is never about stopping
drug abuse it's always got another
political overlay usually suppression of
minorities so
all that means that i think that these
drugs should be available
to people outside of religion outside of
medicine
for a whole range of purposes and that
we should approach it
as recognizing that some of these people
will get into trouble and we need harm
reduction we need pure drugs we need
honest drug education and so i think
that's going to be
the the long-term strategy so in a way
by being a non-profit pharma
we are actually supporting ways for
people to get the drug
without having to get it from us we
would like them to be able to have these
experiences you could even say for
preventative medicine a lot of things
from the fda
like for example all the people that are
health care workers that are getting
traumatized from covet a lot of them
don't have formal ptsd you need chronic
ptsd for six months to be in our study
but preventative
it's not a disease yet but they should
have access to this kind of therapy
so the licensed legalization what that
means is
and this was actually proposed by
timothy leary a long time ago
and he compared it to getting a driver's
license so the importance of it is that
you can have it taken away
it's not that hard to get you have to
learn a certain number of things to do
it
we're going to have thousands of
psychedelic clinics and
people will go to a psychedelic clinic
and say oh i'm interested in lsd or i'm
interested in mdma you go to a
psychedelic clinic
you have the experience under
supervision and you know what you're
getting into
then you get a license and you can go
out and buy it on your own
and then if you misbehave you get
punished for your misbehavior
and then you have your license taken
away for a certain period of time or you
have to go back for an education class
so the best example there is alcohol is
really not regulated the way i think it
should be alcohol should also be
licensed
legalization because you have a bunch of
people that are drunk drivers
and lo and behold they lose their
driver's license for driving under the
influence but they don't lose their
alcohol
ability and they go out and they get
drunk and they go kill people and they
don't have a license
so we should make it harder for people
who misbehave with drugs
to get more drugs and that's the idea of
the licensed legalization
okay well thanks thank you very much
kevin
um and stuart brand uh our founder and
founder of this series
also has a couple questions i believe
welcome stewart
hey rick hi steve i first heard about
mdma being used in
therapeutic mode um by dr rick
richard rockefeller an old friend and
uh i gathered he not only was being an
evangelist for it he started putting
money into it yeah yeah
was he one of your funders and and how
did the
he seem to also get involved in the
political permission that
seemed to be required how is all that
playing out
well richard was actually um well just
to say he was the chairman of the board
of advisors of doctors without borders
and he became aware of
hundreds of thousands millions of
refugees in kosovo and serbia
and he thought these are all traumatized
people what can we do
we don't have enough therapists and
psychiatrists he took an interest in
mdma and we got in touch
and for five years before he died in a
plane crash he was my main thought
partner
wow and he came to me and he said what
is your biggest problem
and i said it's the veterans
administration and the department of
defense they should be
doing this research they have the most
expenditures they have the most
they're causing the most trauma that
they should be the most
uh interested and his cousin was senator
jay rockefeller
who was on the senate veterans affairs
committee so they helped us a lot
richard uh really made the so right now
actually we are waiting to hear from fda
um
any day now about a protocol that we've
submitted inside the bronx va
to do research with mdma we're going to
have to pay for it but
i've been trying for 30 years since 1990
to get permission to do research inside
the va to educate the va
and so to the extent that we will likely
get permission that's due to richard
and his will and so it's it's his legacy
and
richard donated a million dollars to us
um
the rest of his family have also donated
another million dollars um
after richard died
richard died with was that his son clay
or who
well it's his uh sisters his brother
and then after richard died
clay and rebecca his two children they
got together with some of their cousins
and they gathered together half a
million dollars to donate
so richard was tremendous and i think
also one of the most important things
that dr bronner's is one of our big
funders they give us
a million a year for five years they've
just extended it for five more years
and when richard came out to give a
speech at the commonwealth club
with larry brilliant about um mdma which
was introduced a tremendous talk
um david broner basically said my family
you know thinks i'm a little bit out
there but you know they generally like
what i'm doing but if you and richard
would come down and speak to my mother
and speak to my brother
maybe we could increase the amount of
donations that we make
and this is just a sweet story about
richard so he was
president of the rockefeller brothers
foundation and he was turning it over to
a new the next generation
and they were having a big ceremony to
honor him
and he uh postponed it in order
to come down to be with me to speak to
david browner and his family
so richard was just absolutely
instrumental
in doing this um we had meetings in the
pentagon that he arranged he knew
the secretary of the navy um he really
did
all that and i think it was a challenge
that was big enough for him
i think that's why when he said what's
your hardest problem
he knew that he had a lot of capability
to do a lot of things so he wanted to
pick the hardest one and it as it turned
out it was very hard
and we're still i just love hearing that
that's just great to hear thank you
yeah yeah i was so well we were all so
sad when richard died but
he had um basically gotten us to the
point where the national center for ptsd
which is running out of the va
agreed finally to let us
fund a study with one of their
researchers blending mdma with what's
called cognitive behavioral conjoined
therapy but we had to do it the
researchers in their
private capacity not part of the va that
we had to pay for it and the
subjects had to come from outside the va
but that happened shortly before richard
died so he knew
that he had made this switch from uh
having no contact with the va and then
finally letting them give us a little
step forward
wow that's a great story richard was one
of the first funders here
at long now too and we had him on stage
with larry brilliant and
uh now one of our co-chairs of our board
catherine fulton
um for the future of uh philanthropy
which was just really great so
um i think this is uh yeah and
now that richard is uh long gone i think
it's uh
safe to say that he also was learning
how to do therapy
and he was sitting for people and he he
was really taking this whole field to
heart and
he was well he's a doctor he's a
compassionate man and he was
learning to be a therapist with
psychedelics
very cool thank you thank you very much
stewart
um i'm going to ask a few more questions
from wow we have a lot of questions here
coming in
from the audience as you might imagine
as a rich subject
um we have uh let's see
um
i think stephen hubbard on the youtube
feed is asking
more about the potential business models
i think you covered this a little bit i
mean you're kind of involved in one of
these
early business models um with mdma or
other psychedelics as therapy
yeah so um all right so the maps public
benefit corp is about maximizing public
benefit
so the first thing we've assumed is that
the
the training program could be a business
model as well training therapists
but we've decided that we should run the
training program
at our cost because the real public
benefit is healing people from ptsd
and the more therapists that are out
there um the more healing they'll be
done so we're not looking at the
training program
as a business model but there will be
you know thousands of people that will
be training and that
we could have made that into a
participle the next part is the
actual sale of the mdma and so um
mdma is off patent you know as i said
invented by merck in 1912
and i saw a lot of struggles over
intellectual property for a drug called
ibogaine
and it had a use patent for the
treatment of opiate addiction so i just
thought that that was so destructive to
the whole movement for ibogaine
that i contacted their patent attorney
and i asked him to develop an
anti-patent strategy so nobody could
patent any of the uses of mdma
so so there's no business model that way
unless somebody comes up with some new
use that we've you know
never heard of or that's never been
written about
okay then there's a certain kind of
patents you can have over
process patents over the production of
the mdma
the encapsulation there's certain
intellectual property that's never been
done before we're going to make all that
public so our main
business model is selling mdma and the
way that that works is that in 1984
ronald reagan signed a law to provide
incentives for developing drugs that are
off patent and those incentives are
called data exclusivity
and so what that means is that if you're
the first to make a drug into a medicine
that's off patent that automatically the
fda gives you
five years where no one can use your
data you have exclusive use of your data
no one can use it to market generic and
fda is now also realizing that a lot of
drugs that are approved in
adults are marketed to kids without any
information so
they are requiring us now if we succeed
in adults to do studies in adolescence
with ptsd
and you get an extra six months data
exclusivity for that
and it blocks a generic manufacturer
from applying until that five and a half
years is over takes fda at least
six months so it's going to be six years
in europe it's ten years data
exclusivity
so that's one model selling then the
other
main business model is going to be the
clinics where
are these drugs actually going to be
delivered
and as i said they're only going to be
delivered by trained therapists under
direct supervision
so you could imagine um networks of
clinics
we're actually looking at more and more
of a model where
we want these clinics to be locally
owned not
like a franchise well franchise can be
locally owned
but we're not trying to maps have uh you
know thousand clinics
and the other thing to say about the
clinics is that we're talking about
psychedelic psychotherapy not just mdma
so the therapists all want to be
cross-trained they want to know ketamine
they want to know
mdma they want to know suicide but
they're eventually going to want to know
you know dmt ayahuasca ibogaine whatever
comes down
through the fda so they're they're not
going to be like a maps clinic we we
will have
um certain everybody that we train will
be on a list
and they'll be able to access the drug
and treat patients but they can innovate
and they do whatever they want
and that's fine that's you know the
practice of medicine however
for those people that want to continue
to use our treatment manual
we will say they're map certified and so
you will know
if you go to a clinic these are people
that are innovating it could even be
better than our model but
you know if you go to a map certified
clinic but it could also be
a compass certified clinic or a usona
certified clinic or
so that people will be cross-trained so
i think the the business models that
we're still
just starting to understand and explore
are these network of clinics
gotcha and um i think we had a few
questions here
um so i think that follow up on that i
mean one for instance a drug that's
already being used in some
cases not necessarily therapeutic but
certainly um
maybe with therapy therapy in mind is
ketamine
um uh can you say how that fits into
this space
yeah yeah so um i think the
patenting and uh the farm-up side of
this i think is interesting yeah
yeah so ketamine was the main
battlefield anesthetic in vietnam
so it's an old drug and it's really good
because it doesn't interfere with your
respiration
so that you can be um you could
self-administer it and you inject it it
doesn't have to go
iv you just inject it into muscle too so
the
main molecule ketamine is generic and
it's just
very inexpensive so what a
pharmaceutical company did
anesthesiologists started to notice that
as people were coming out of operations
those that
had been depressed before some of them
were no longer
so depressed and that led to so it was a
serendipitous
finding a bunch of myself loads of
people that i know
um in the psychedelic community have
explored ketamine as a psychedelic
but a lot of us completely missed the
idea that it was an antidepressant
because we weren't depressed so we
didn't have the before and after
but the national institute of mental
health started looking at this and so a
pharmaceutical company picked it up
but what they realized is why are they
going to do research with a generic drug
that how are they going to make their
money back so they took one of the
isomers
so a drug is called racemic it's got
sort of left hand and right hand
and these molecules are the same but
because they're mirror images they fit
in different places in the brain
and so there the different isomers have
different effects
so uh jansen and johnson johnson worked
on
s ketamine which is one of the isomers
and they've made that
into a medicine for depression and this
is
and they've got a patent on that because
no one thought to make an isomer into
a medicine for depression and what
they've
done the data exclusivity side or is
this because of the isomer
yeah it's its own pattern yeah yeah and
um
so but this is a i think a a bad example
of for-profit pharma because
maximizing profit not patient outcomes
because when you
they're treating s ketamine as if
it's a strictly pharmacological
treatment and that
you don't need any support and they
sometimes have
we had a fellow named pine who was an
early um
bitcoin investor and he donated five and
a quarter
million dollars worth of bitcoins to us
he gave away around um
56 million dollars worth of bitcoins
this is uh late 2017 early 2018 but he
did
he was depressed and he had borderline
personality disorder and he went for
ketamine therapy
and he had this vision that the way
for him to get out of his problems was
to help other people
which is a very simple brilliant insight
and he he wanted to tell the therapist
about this and they said we don't care
what happened
it's all about this physiological thing
forget about the story
you know and when he learned about that
what we did was combining therapy with
the drug he said that's the model he
wanted but when you do combine
therapy with s ketamine you get better
results it's the whole integration
process
that that that you need afterwards but
you'll end up
needing fewer ketamine sessions and
that's not going to be so good for the
pharmaceutical company so they
market this in a sub-optimal way for
patient outcomes
but in a way for them to try to make the
most money but what they've also done to
kind of
um well what what's happening now is a
lot of the people who are prescribing
ketamine
or s ketamine have realized why should
they pay 500 bucks or whatever
to this pharmaceutical company when they
can buy generic ketamine for
a dollar or two dollars and
the insurance companies you know
sometimes you could work with them to
cover some of the therapy
so what we see happening more and more
is that therapists are working with the
generic
cheap ketamine rather than the s
ketamine
and they're adding thera therapy to it
but still there's
there's an awful lot of people
anesthesiologists a lot of times now
are using ketamine in electroconvulsive
therapy ect
suites so a lot of anesthesiologists who
are not therapists are just
finding a new income source to give
ketamine because anesthesiologists use
ketamine for operations
and they just use these ect suites and
they just line them up and give them
ketamine and
but the benefits tend to fade after time
sometimes even after a week or a few
days
but some people do get enough sessions
they they get over their
uh depression permanently but i think
it's an example of really
profit maximization rather than um
optimizing for patient benefits
but ketamine is a great drug for
depression and for other
and for psychotherapy and uh chris
chatham
um from one of our feeds asked about
this too and i think you've mentioned it
now with the
with this which is this what about these
fast follower
um kind of small changes to the molecule
in order to create these patented
situations do you think there's
opportunities for that in mdma or some
psilocybin or anything
well not really i don't think so i mean
sasha shulgin who
um you know he tinkered with um hundreds
of drugs of the molecule
of mdma variations and he said there's a
book a movie a documentary about him
called dirty pictures and in in the
documentary what he says is
of all the mdma-like drugs he thinks
mdma was the most effective but
you could imagine people could tinker
with it but one of the reasons why we're
not
interested in that is first off we
couldn't afford it because
if you have a new molecule you have to
do enormous number of safety studies
with mdma because tens of millions of
people have taken it because governments
all over the world have tried to
demonize it
and focused on the risks there's over
five thousand papers in medline
and we know an awful lot about it
at around 450 million dollars so i think
what we really need is new social
contexts for legal access
in therapy in religion in other ways
but you know i think that there will be
for-profit people will come along
and if they can tinker with the
molecules and make them better
all you know all more power to them
we're not against it but we're just not
trying to do it ourselves and i think
that
it's unlikely that they're going to
develop something better than psilocybin
that's around for thousands of years or
you know who knows one of the things
that people could be doing is trying to
shorten the span of it
so let's say you can get um like five
meow dmt
you know that's like a 10 minute thing
or dmt if you smoke it's a 10 minute
thing so
we find that the eight-hour session is
actually really good it's not a
problem that it's that long it permits
people to do an awful lot of work in
still a relatively short amount of time
but you could imagine drugs that are
manufactured and designed to be
a half hour and then you can do it i
don't know that you'd get better
outcomes but
but you know i never knew when i um knew
all about psychedelics from the 70s when
i learned about
mdma i initially dismissed it and then
when i tried it i was like oh my god
this is really great this is
a new development so you know let's hope
that they find new stuff that's great
cool um shell cappen from our feed um is
asking about the
kind of the politic politicization of
some of the federal agencies that you're
working with and how they've
hallowed out recently or um is that
what is the current where does the
current climate fit into some of the
work that you're doing does it cause
fast tracking or slow tracking or what
um we we have once um
let me say this that the we we do not
currently ex
feel that we're experiencing any
political obstruction whatsoever
so for example on may 1 the
disabled american veterans put out their
bi-monthly magazine
to 1.3 members of disabled american
veterans and the cover article
was about mdma ptsd one point three
million i assume one point three
yes yeah yeah that's great yeah yeah
yeah so
we are um we have bipartisan support for
what we're doing
um you know rebecca mercer who was one
of the funders of trump and bannon and
cambridge analytica is one of our
funders and her only limitation was
this has to go to veterans so we feel
that we have bipartisan support we have
veterans with the
with the conservative forces more our
supportive of
uh first responders we've treated uh
firefighters we've treated
police officers multiple police officers
actually so
the the way that these other agencies
have been hollowed out
has been i would say the tragic
systematic destruction of the state
department the department of justice
um attempts to overly politicize them
but the fda is still more
science over politics and if when it
comes to the upper levels if there are
politics
i think the politics are on our side so
because of covet 19
the fda is contacting all of the people
that are in the midst of clinical trials
and offering them the opportunity to end
the study early
so the more subjects you have in the
study the more likely you are to get
statistical significance so it's a bit
of a risk to end the study
sooner with fewer numbers of subjects
but what we propose back to the fda
is that we would end the study with 90
subjects
who would have their baseline and at
least one
of their primary their measures
after at least one experimental session
so our model is three experimental
sessions
one month apart and these 12 90-minute
non-drug sessions
so we can have we'll have some missing
data because some people
had started and then covered they were
quarantined they didn't want to go for
more treatment but
we think that the fda will agree to this
and we should have the data by the end
of june
and then we'll have the data lock and
statistical analysis before the end of
august and then we'll know if this
subject
this first of two phase three studies
succeeded
and so we're in a good situation
negotiating with the fda we are in this
formal dispute about the credentials
so we do have some disagreements with
them i think the credentials of the
uh the people the therapists yeah yeah
yeah yes
well um first of all i just want to
thank you so much i'm
so excited to have had you tonight and
um
i'm really glad that we got to share
this with our community um we did send
out a link to
our members we're trying yet another
experiment in our after event
discussions
um and so please do check your email for
that
and i know at least some of our staff
and others are going to join uh i know
rick you may have another
obligation but we'll see if we can get
you for a little bit um
and i think um i just want to thank you
for the compassion
um and the science that you've brought
to this uh field that has really
lacked that uh in any formal sense and
and you and maps have done a fantastic
job so thank you
so much yeah and well it started with uh
the whole earth catalog and reading
about
john lilly i mean this is i've been
waiting for this for a long time this is
so nice to
kind of participate with you in this way
i'm so glad it worked out thank you so
much please hang out with us we'll
see you in the studio
you